hey this is Stevie TV and I am reviewing
the mummy
no not Brendan Fraser's mummy if you
want to see that review you're going to
find a VHS of me when I was 10 but I am
reviewing Tom Cruise's mummy and I
wasn't crazier the casting of Tom Cruise
in this movie and I'm not enjoying his
performance in this movie the character
wasn't written well so it's not all his
fault but it's still Tom Cruise Tom
Cruise one of those guys he's in a movie
he plays Tom Cruise and I see him as Tom
Cruise and I was just time cruisers
running through the money mummy and dark
universe and it's frustrating so I felt
like that was distracting and it was
just Tom Cruise he's past that
expiration date an older actor now kind
of felt like when you watch Harrison
Ford in the fourth Indiana Jones there's
just an old guy now it's not the same
Tom Cruise we know loved when he was in
Top Gun and the early Mission Impossible
movie so peach is forking the flirtation
with the character Jenny he's forcing
the wick and it was kind of also mailing
it in too so it was strange to see Tom
Cruise in this role definitely missed
cast the female lead Jenny was alright
but she was kind of bland nothing really
about her character I still don't feel
like I know anything about her she was
cool she was you know a strong female
lead but she wasn't interesting that was
a problem the comic relief his friend
Chris that was really weird because he's
in the beginning and his jokes are just
bombing I don't think he's that funny
and I seen it before it's like a tired
formula and then he just gets killed by
Nick and then you see him come back is
as weird like mummy hallucination to Tom
Cruise and it was just too convenient
because the friend was just guiding him
where to go in his head so it was so
weird and kind of a cheap storyline wise
but part I did like in the movie I
didn't hate this movie as much as the
critics did I thought it was
entertaining and a part of liked was the
dr. Jekyll introduction Russell Crowe I
think he plays a good dr. Jekyll it's
more interesting or refreshing because
now this is opening up the dark universe
which is all these former classic
monster stories from Universal that
they're remaking I like the idea of it
it's different because it's not
superhero zone everyone's doing now so
it's a breath of fresh air I thought it
was interesting because it was didn't
feel like totally like a remake of the
mummy
we see dr. Jekyll's lab and he's
studying the monsters and he was a cool
connection of all these creatures that
are going to come about and it was
really cool seeing the creature of the
Black Moon like maybe I was his hand in
that jar that was probably my favorite
moment to get me like hyped and we of
course I got the Bride of Frankenstein
coming Frankenstein was going to be
played by Javier Bardem primary star
might be Angelina Jolie should be sick
so quick cited for that but the star was
the mommy was a little weird kick off
this dark universe series and it
distracted in the sense that it didn't
feel like a mummy movie because they
knew they were opening this universe and
I had to introduce all this stuff with
dr. Jekyll so maybe would have been
better fridges made a dr. Jekyll movie
to start and introduce his whole idea
about studying creatures and monsters
instead of putting it on the mummy
because it just didn't work and it made
all the character of element in this
mummy movie feel rushed and it didn't
really feel like a mummy movie just felt
like introduction to the dark universe
with some mommy elements however I did
like the villain I think she was a good
mummy
princess I'm Annette and I think that I
wish we saw more of her I think she
played it well and she was cool and she
was scary but she had disappointing
final battle there with her and Tom
Cruise just fighting each other and I
wasn't crazy with Tom proving the power
of you know I think it's pot or whatever
that guy correct means I'm definitely
wrong with that but the other guy that
the woman was trying to use and he gets
this guy's power and he can resurrect
people so he resurrects Jenny and then
he resurrects his friend in the desert
it was kind of just like really that's
the power and I was just was another
like praise she's praising and like you
sacrificed yourself for me but really
dimming cuz he's alive he's fine and
then he keeps saying he's cursed the
curse saved him from dying from that
plane so like how is that a courtesy he
got the good end of it at least because
his friend got screwed up but he gets to
live and he resurrects people so I was
kind of weird and it was written weird
but uh overall it wasn't terrible it's
like again it's not a great movie but
it's one of those pretty bad movies
that's still entertaining it's not
boring so that it was grateful for it
while movies are just born
but this was still some good action
sequences I still enjoyed it as a movie
it's a popcorn flick but obviously start
being a worthless disappointment and Tom
Cruise Luna Ray casting and it's no
branden frasier mommy come on people you
can't beat that
but overall I'm excited for the dark
universe and what's to come I will give
this movie though a 6 wasn't great but
it wasn't as bad as people were saying I
still think it's something to check out
and hopefully take it as just an
introduction and get excited for what's
to come with the dark universe because I
have faith in Universal I hope they do
the right thing and make these a little
more scarier than this one and some more
character development for sure because I
did not feel attached to this movie or
any connections of humanity at all it
was all over the place but hopefully the
next one will be better and please come
back to watch my reviews I review a
bunch of shows I just finishing up
federal solid review leftovers and I'm
going to about to be reviewing a
preacher and Game of Thrones and I'll be
removing revealing a movie every week so
please subscribe I'm so grateful if you
do and I am comment below I respond to
everybody please give this video a like
and thank you for watching and follow ex
TV TV show on Twitter Instagram and ask
the volley one